what is your sign
I'm a Leo see I don't know what any of
this means so you just asked it did you
so I'm I'm I know I just know I'm an
aquarius okay Leo's in Aquarius they get
along well we get along yeah we get
along what who don't you get along with
Scorpios let's say you go out on a date
with a guy and you find out he's a
Scorpio is that a rap yeah we probably
didn't even get along during the day but
what if you did get along and like
everything was going great and then he
was like I was born on October 24th and
then you're like
yeah they're just full of so
probably really yeah they're sneaky like
it probably went so great and I probably
think the world is like pieces and
creams with them but I just know deep
down there full of really yeah